Hello, I'm Kenneth Powers.
People ask me what's it like being the CEO of K-Swiss.
Well, it's basically the same as being the CEO of any other sports company...
...only 100 times better.
I didn't just sign the baddest athletes; I hired them to run the company.
Like Matt Cassel, my new VP of Marketing.
K-Swiss Tubes: We Let the Dogs Out.
Emphasis on "we".
Who did it?
We did it.
It's good, Cassel.
I brought in Jon "Bones" Jones to run HR.
Shorter lunches, what is that? I'm taking a long lunch.
Oh, wait!
For Director of Community Outreach, I got the ultimate people person: Jillian Michaels.
You want to look like a burrito on your prom dress huh, blondie?
But being the CEO isn't just about firing people,...
...I'm changing the sports world.
Gentlemen, I present to you the athlete of the future...
Kill him, Patrick Willis.
...wearing the training shoe of the future.
Tubes: lightweight, breathable upper top part where the laces are.
I'm changing the business world.
Mark Cuban, I will pay you 25 million dollars if you change your team's name to the Dallas K-Swiss Tubes.
Hell no.
I'm even changing the whole world, world.
Now that is how you run a company like Kenny Powers.
Hot secretary, give me the president on the line.
I just got tired of paying taxes.